joining us live now from Bristol is at
the business secretary great client mr.
Clarke very good morning to you just in
terms of what you're eating there yeah
morning just in terms of what you're
heating there from the Institute of
Economic Affairs I mean politicians have
been completely incompetent
I suspect you disagree with that
assessment I don't Fred didn't hear
everything that went before but in terms
of the of the consequences of No Deal I
think businesses large and small all
recognize that the that we need to have
an agreement the idea of having the
uncertainty of literally not knowing
what our trading relationship is going
to be with our most important trading
partner is not something that they that
we can contemplate with any kind of
complacency we have to have a good
agreement not least because this is I'm
here in Bristol we're talking about
aerospace today we're talking about life
sciences these are sectors that are
booming around the world in which
Britain has huge strengths we're leading
the world and we want to get investments
made to take advantage of those
opportunities but there was always the
possibility that there might at the end
of the process by the time we reach
March next year that there might not be
any deal on any deal struck can you just
confirm in your view is the United
Kingdom ready for an audio brexit well
we we can make the preparations
that are possible to make and we've
published throughout the the an
indication of what steps businesses
would need to take in that venture ality
but some things simply can't be avoided
for example you know the the bulk of our
just-in-time manufacturing trade goes
through the Straits of Dover whether the
Channel Tunnel or the between Dover and
Calais
that's that whole route that that system
is based on having no customs checks
it's kind of rolling most ways all your
viewers know who use it it's very
effective you can get car components
being installed without any warehousing
required four hours notice that's the
way it operates and it's simply not
possible and it wouldn't be possible
even from the day after the the
referendum to build at the entrance of
the Channel Tunnel for example huge
customs sheds that there wouldn't be at
the time but actually for if your
viewers know the the the folks in area
and it's been through the Channel Tunnel
you know it's between two cliffs there
isn't the space for that so that's a
good example of how we need to have an
agreement in order to avoid it would be
crazy to to disrupt at a time of
prospective great prosperity in these
industries to to introduce not just
obstacles but really to to destroy some
of the the foundations of the success of
some of our most brilliant industries
mister cart just to pick up and what was
something that you just said there you
said that if we had started on the day
that we voted on the day of the
referendum we wouldn't have been ready
by now okay not may well be true but we
didn't need to trigger an article fifty
did we that's the problem with
urinalysis that actually if we had
delayed triggering article fifty
everyone you know deal was an option we
could have been ready for the prospect
of an ordeal Brack said well I
understand that that argument but if you
think back and it's hard to to do so
during that length of time but actually
what the European Union said was that
they they wouldn't even begin to to have
any discussions until we triggered
article fifty we were a full member
until and continuing member until we
triggered article fifty that was the the
notification that we intended to to
leave and it's and it's hard to to kind
of go back and remember that very clear
view that until we'd serve notice to to
leave they couldn't have conversations
and so we didn't have a strategy without
is start with the pronunciations let
alone I'm sorry mister but we didn't
have a strategy when we started the
negotiations let alone having the
capacity to deal with an ordeal brexit
it has always been an option the
suggestion that many people are making
it has been a
election of the responsibilities of this
government we have a situation in which
the Chancellor in front of the committee
yesterday said you know two years might
be pushing it we might even take longer
than two years you knew you knew your
deal was an option we haven't prepared
for it I I don't agree with that and if
you think of a a relationship of over
forty years in which our supply chains
have been developed it together on the
basis of this being an in industries
talk about aerospace talked about life
sciences you can talk about automotive
that have grown up together these were
always that they're very deeply enmeshed
two years was never going to be enough
to be able to to separate them but we
shouldn't want to separate them if we
want to to succeed and we want to create
new jobs let alone keeping the millions
of jobs that depend on our success let's
be clear this is success we are one of
the most successful countries in the
world at some of in the industries that
are expanding in the future automotive
aerospace life sciences satellites these
are the areas that are growing we have a
fantastic reputation aerospace today
we're going to be launching a new deal
with the aerospace sector we are the
number two aerospace industry in the
whole world second only to the US there
are waiting lists for four aeroplanes
right across the the world we are the
wing capital of the world
for the aerospace industry we should be
erasing those opportunities to do so we
need to be able to trade without
frictions with our European partners as
well as the rest of the world well I
suppose the good thing about the
aviation industry is it doesn't require
car parks at the Port of Dover just in
terms of the votes coming next week
there have been reports this morning
just on that other point the the
aviation industry is the aerospace
industry is is a good example of where
it relies on just-in-time production
there isn't we don't make whole
aeroplanes we contribute to the valuable
construction of aeroplanes that are made
in right across Europe and across the
the world and we we run
lie on being able to get components just
in time to install and if you've got to
wait or if there's any doubts that they
might be held up in customs delays that
is not a sustainable basis on which to
have an industry that is creating
hundreds of thousands of jobs very
well-paid jobs the jobs in the aerospace
industry pay forty percent above the the
national average this is one of the
expanding industries of the future we've
got one of the best reputations in the
world we mustn't do anything that would
hamper that we should be as we are doing
in Bristol today investing in it
embracing those opportunities in the
future indeed I just want a very quick
question as we're coming to our end of
our time with you Mr Clarke the vote on
Tuesday categorically that is going to
happen a suggestion this morning that
there have been at colleagues reviewers
within the party within the cabinet
ojung perhaps to think again
because it could be fatal for your
administration now I think we need to
have the vote we need to press on I'm
with businesses all day today they want
an end to the uncertainty they want to
know with confidence what our future
trading relationship is going to be I
think the the deal that's been put
forward and and is being scrutinized by
the House of Commons I think is it's
fair to the to the 52% that that voted
leave we're leaving the European Union
where we'll be able to have our own free
trade agreements to set our own
migration policy will be out of the CFP
out of the Common Agricultural Policy we
won't be making annual payments that is
clearly implementing the result of the
referendum but crucially it's had the
backing of business and you know this
having reported it over the last few
days and weeks business regards this
deal as providing the necessary
conditions for them to invest with
confidence in the future there is a wall
of investment that is waiting to be
built waiting to be invested in this
country once we we can provide the
certainty that they regard this deal as
giving for the future prospects for
trade with the European Union and
therefore the rest of the world